today on the matt walsh show indiana
university celebrates a psychopathic
pedophile while hollywood celebrates a
gang of bloodthirsty slave traders these
are our new historical heroes to replace
the old and much better ones also the
regime uses the solemn occasion of 911
to further demonize their political
opponents ron desantis upsets the left
and libertarians with his latest speech
byu has completed its investigation into
the invisible man who silently shouted
the n-word at a volleyball game and our
daily cancellation that new hillary
clinton show on apple tv
is far worse than you could have ever
imagined all of that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the supreme court decision to overturn
roe is a huge albeit long overdue step
in the right direction but there's still
a long way to go to read our country of
abortion finally many companies are
bowing to the woke mob by donating the
uh to pro-choice causes and candidates
or reimbursing their employees travel
expenses so that if they live and work
in a pro-life state they can travel to a
pro-abortion state get an abortion and
be back at work on monday but what if i
told you that if you're currently on a
phone plan with one of the major
carriers you might be supporting these
companies and their pro-abortion agendas
with your monthly phone bill don't let
abortionists use your money to fund
policies you don't believe and switch to
charity mobile instead charity mobile is
a pro-life pro family cell phone company
that sends five percent of your monthly
plan price to the pro-life charity of
your choice you don't have to compromise
on values or good phone service charity
mobile offers the latest 5g phones no
device or service contracts great
nationwide coverage and live customer
service based right here in the usa the
fight for the right to life continues
and pro-life causes need your support
you can help today by simply switching
your phone service to charity mobile
call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem a free cell phone that's
charitymobile.com and mention code walsh
the war on history ongoing for years now
has two phases the first phase is to
demonize all of our cultures historical
heroes turn them into a cartoon villains
basically downplay their successes and
virtues while emphasizing their
shortcomings and shortcomings and if
they did not have enough shortcomings to
emphasize then simply invent evil deeds
that they didn't actually commit
and this is easy enough to do it's not
like they're around to defend themselves
from the slander so you can say whatever
you want about them then tear down their
statues take their names off of
buildings turn them into sources of
national shame whereas before they were
sources of national pride the left has a
word actually for this first phase it's
problematize
which is to make a problem out of
something or someone that was not a
problem before
now it's safe to say at this point
that phase one the problematization
phase is complete
that moves us to phase two
with the old heroes smoldering on the
historical ash heat their monuments all
knocked over and decaying like the
statue of liberty and the planet of the
apes the next step is to replace them
with new heroes
and where the old heroes were great men
and women who accomplished magnificent
and world-changing things yet also being
human-possessed flaws sometimes great
flaws the new heroes accomplished
nothing worthwhile at all they are
selected not because of their
achievements but because of their
usefulness their utility
to the leftist cultural narrative
obviously the george floyd murals and
statues are the prime example of this
and also this
indiana university proudly announces on
their website today quote
a new bronze sculpture memorializing
alfred c kinsey's significant and
enduring contributions to indiana
university now sits on the bloomington
campus marking the 75th anniversary of
the institute that bears his name kinsey
revolutionized the scientific study of
sexual behavior and provoked an
international conversation about
sexuality he founded the kinsey
institute the world's leading sexuality
research institute in 1947. the
life-size bronze is the work of melanie
cooper pennington a lecturer in the
sculpture in sculpture in the iu
school of art and architecture design
the sculptures installation on the
bloomington campus demonstrates the
university's pride in the living legacy
of research and academic freedom kinsey
helped to forge and the institute's
ongoing commitment to equity regarding
sexual diversity established by kinsey's
research equity regarding sexual
diversity well that's one way to put it
the other way to put it is that alfred
kinsey was a deviant lunatic and a
pedophile who enjoyed um
researching quote unquote the orgasms of
children and babies
the notorious table 34 from the book
sexual behavior in the human mail
documents the number of orgasms
allegedly experienced by children
from the ages of 15 down to 5 months old
and he acquired this
information
by working with rapists who would abuse
children keep a journal about the
experience and then report back to
kinsey
so in other words he enlisted pedophiles
to rape kids so that he could get the
data he wanted and why did he want this
data well because he wished to prove
that children are sexual beings from
birth
and that all forms of sexual activity
literally all forms including pedophilia
bestiality all of it are legitimate
now you can learn more about this in my
film what is a woman and uh where we
discuss
uh in more length alfred kinsey and also
john money
but this is the man that indiana
university honors with his own statue he
was the most prolific groomer of the
20th century
there's a reason that the left still
celebrates him today but of course
calling them groomers is hate speech
i mean they're making statues to alfred
kinsey but calling them groomers as hate
speech
yet it's not just child raping
psychopaths who we're being told to
honor this week they're also slave
traders we mustn't forget about them
well only certain historical slave
traders are worthy of our admiration
specifically the ones whose story is
being told in a major hollywood film
which is set to premiere this coming
friday the movie is called the woman
king
and the absurdity of the title the woman
king is really the least of its problems
so we don't even have time to talk about
that the official description on rotten
tomatoes tells us this
the woman king is the remarkable story
of the agoji the all-female unit of
warriors who protected the alfred the
african kingdom of dahomey in the 1800s
with skills and a fierceness unlike
anything the world has ever seen
inspired by true events the woman king
follows the emotionally epic journey of
general nanesika as she trains the next
generation of recruits and reads them
for battle against an enemy determined
to destroy their way of life
we'll have a little bit more on their
way of life and what exactly that way of
life was in just a second but here's a
little bit of the trailer
watch an evil is coming
that threatens our kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
they are not prepared for
[Applause]
[Music]
my king the europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop until the whole of
africa is theirs
we must fight back
for our people
palestine
[Applause]
some things
are worth fighting for
don't know
train hard fight harder
we fear no one
and we fear no pain
i offer you a choice
fight
or we die
now to be clear this film is about as
historically accurate as
like the power rangers but we'll get
back to that in a second it's of course
a foregone conclusion that this movie
will be critically acclaimed it has to
be i mean it's essentially a matter of
law or might as well be at this point
that a story about female african
warriors killing europeans
must be praised in the most rapturous
terms possible any critic who dares to
utter a critique or whose applause is
judged to be lacking in enthusiasm will
be branded a racist and a sexist
and they'll probably throw transphobe
and homophobe in for good measure also
mainstream film critics who as a group
uh are some of the most pathetic cowards
in all of media which is really really
saying something
certainly got the memo about this
reviews of the film were released on
sunday
and the woman king now boasts a 100
fresh rating on rotten tomatoes if it
keeps going at this pace which it
probably will it will go down as one of
the most best reviewed films of all time
right now it's ahead of uh like citizen
kane and the godfather
in terms of its of its uh reviews
critics are saying things like the woman
king is a sturdy rousing piece of studio
entertainment that makes both the new
feel old and the old feel new then also
thrilling and enrapturing emotionally
beautiful and spiritually buoyant the
woman king isn't just an uplifting
battle cry it's the movie that director
prince by the way has been building
toward her entire career
and then
fierce furious and feminine an action
picture that isn't so much released as
unleashed talk about a movie of its
moment
another critic adds that the movie is so
spectacular so perfect so wonderful so
miraculous and beautiful he's planning
to jump out of a window as soon as he
submits his review having decided that
his life has reached its pinnacle and
there's no point of living anymore it's
all downhill from here another one said
that watching the movie was more
glorious than seeing the birth of his
own children
and in fact after the watching living he
wishes that his children had not been
born because they're white
now admittedly i made up the last two
reviews but they're not very far from
what the critics are actually saying
all of this
in spite of the fact that the kingdom of
dahomey
who are the heroes of this movie
were ruthless killers and slave traders
who conquered and murdered in pursuit of
slaves which were then used as labor
within the kingdom or sold to buyers
outside of the kingdom
as the encyclopedia britannica notes um
before they edit this passage which i'm
sure they will
uh the kingdom was was not just that
they had slaves the kingdom was
fundamentally organized around war and
slavery that's what the whole thing was
about
uh quote dahomey was organized for war
not only to expand its boundaries but
also to take captives as slaves slaves
were either sold to the europeans in
exchange for weapons or kept to work the
royal plantations that supplied food for
the army in court
from approximately 1680 a regular census
of population was taken as a basis for
military conscription female soldiers
called amazons by the europeans served
as royal bodyguards when not in combat
so
the trans-atlantic slave trade
could only exist because it was
furnished by dahomey along with other
tribes and kingdoms
this is one of the little-known
inconvenient facts about african slavery
we've talked about before on the show it
was a system supported encouraged
promoted facilitated by
africans themselves
now
in the homies case i should be fair i
guess and admit that they didn't always
sell their captives into slavery
sometimes they would um
instead of selling them
butcher them in human sacrifice rituals
human sacrifices were killed for various
rituals to honor kings and then also uh
there were other forms of human
sacrifices like the concubines of a king
would be killed and buried with him when
he died
those sorts of things now naturally
all indications are this movie does not
really grapple with any of these
unfortunate historical realities on the
contrary
they paint the female warriors of
dahomey as as as freedom fighters
according to one review i read they do
acknowledge that the kingdom had slaves
but they pretend that the woman warriors
were abolitionists
that they were pushing for the end of
the slave trade which is pure fiction of
course
actually not only is it fiction
but the slave trade only ended
in the kingdom of dahomey because
british blockades forced it to end
here's another inconvenient fact
europeans abolished the slave trade
above the objections of many african and
middle eastern nations
so europeans said you're not doing this
none of us are doing slave trade anymore
it's done
while many african and middle eastern
nations said no we want to keep doing
the slave thing because it's it's
profitable to us
now as for the woman warriors of dahomey
they were easily crushed in their first
military engagement with the french and
that's was the end of that story
now look
there's nothing
on the surface wrong with you know
making a movie that fictionalizes
historical events
but it is unthinkable of course that
anything like this could ever be
produced
much less receive rave reviews if the
roles were flipped around imagine
imagine a civil war movie where the
confederates are not only the heroes of
the film but are portrayed as the true
abolitionists
you know that's just that movie could
not possibly exist and if it did exist
there would be literal riots in the
street i mean it's not an exaggeration
to say there would be riots the
buildings would be burning if a movie
like that
was it came out
any theater that was crazy enough to
play it would be burned to the ground
except
that wouldn't even be on par with this
film because the confederates were not
nearly as brutal as the kingdom of
dahomey was
but this is all a part of our cultural
rewrite of history
you know some men who had slaves were
bad no matter what else they did
thomas jefferson george washington no
matter what else they did
even as the founders of
our country they had slaves so we got to
tear down their statues they were
scumbags that's it
while other people who organized their
whole societies around the capture sale
and ritualistic murder of slaves were
good
and deserving of their own
hagiographical films
so once again our culture designates new
heroes for us
and those new heroes might be criminals
drug addicts child rapists
even slave traders
not much to admire there but we're told
to
admire them all the same
now let's get to our five headlines
well these data breaches just keep
coming this one is uh is regional but
it's big and it includes social security
numbers
nelnet servicing a technology service
company used by oklahoma student loan
authority and ed financial announced a
breach affecting 2.5 million student
borrowers breached information includes
social security numbers emails phone
numbers addresses all that stuff is
included that's why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
your personal information gets exposed
so often that it's dangerously easy for
a cyber criminal to steal your identity
that's why protecting your identity is
so important and is also easy with life
lock by norden lifelock detects and
alerts you to potential identity threats
that you may not spot on your own like
if a loan is taken out in your name if
you do become a victim of identity theft
a dedicated us-based restoration
specialist will work to fix it nobody
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but it's easy to help protect
yourself with lifelock by norton
identity theft protection starts here
join now and save 25 off your first year
at lifelock.com walsh that's
lifelock.com walsh for 25 off
well yesterday was of course the 21st
anniversary of 9 11 each year that we
move
farther away from it
the more it becomes especially for my
kids generation
and gen z
uh in historical event which is kind of
strange to think about for those of
those of us who live through it
uh it's it's very strange to consider
that when our twins are born our latest
set of twins anyway 911 will be farther
away from them
than the moon landing
was for me when i was born and the moon
landing always felt like ancient history
to me from the first moment i learned
about it you know it felt like it might
as well have been 600 years ago
and it's sort of sad to reflect on that
for a few reasons first it's sad to
reflect
on just how far back the moon landing
was not only because we really didn't
haven't done anything else with mandex
space exploration since then but also
because the moon landing
was the last
so far as i can think
was the last truly great moment
of national celebration that this
country has had
the last one was in 1969 we haven't had
another one
um it's hard to think of any moment
since then when the whole country
together
celebrated something
a landmark occasion where we all
celebrated every land we've had landmark
occasions since then but every landmark
occasion since the moon landing and
especially in my own life has been bad
you know the times that you can think of
big news events that you remember years
after the fact columbine 911 the iraq
war those sorts of things
so
that's a very tragic thing and it
actually helps explain why my generation
and generations after mine have sort of
turned out the way they have
as for 9 11 it's sad to think of how
long ago it was not because um it's
something we want to relive obviously
but because
the farther we move away from 911 the
farther we move
from pre-911 america and pre-911
was
simply a different world in a lot of
ways a different country
and i think a better one
in nearly every way
the country we all knew the lives we
knew fell with the towers that's the
truth and
these are all things that i think are
worth reflecting on but these are not
the things that the current regime wants
us to reflect on or think about on 9 11.
instead they want us to think about the
new enemy
you know the the new al qaeda which is
even worse than the old al qaeda
and we're not talking about a new
al-qaeda
in afghanistan the middle east uh but no
right right here in this country because
the new enemy is you and me
as biden made clear in a in a not so
subtle way in his 9 11 speech let's
listen to this
it's not enough to gather and remember
each september 11th
those we lost more than two decades ago
because on this day
it is not about the past it's about the
future we have an obligation
a duty a responsibility to defend
preserve and protect our democracy
the very democracy that guarantees the
rights of freedom that those terrorists
of 9 11 sought to bury
in the burning fire and smoke and ash
now if you didn't know any better if you
if you
maybe had been stranded at sea on a
desert island or something since the
actual 911
and you heard that from
the president
you might think okay well that's that's
fine
you know he's talking about defending
democracy and freedom pretty standard
political boilerplate stuff you might
think
except we know what he actually means
when he talks about the threat to
democracy because we know in context uh
every other time he's talked about that
what's actually meant he's made clear
what that threat is and who it is
camilla harris on 911 i think was even
more explicit about this let's listen to
that
look we're at the 21st
marking if you will of the september
11th attacks this was a foreign
terrorist attacking our democracy
attacking this country
we're now as a nation battling a threat
from within is the threat
equal or greater than what we faced
after 9 11
that's an interesting question um i have
held
many elected offices as district
attorney attorney general senator now
vice president and there's an oath that
we always take
which is
to
defend and uphold our constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
and
we don't compare the two in the oath
but we know they both can exist and we
must defend against it
well the uh the correct answer to that
is no i mean he's saying the threat from
domestic enemies to the constitution
meaning mega republicans meaning
you know half of the country if not more
uh are is it on par with the threat of
uh
you know the terrorist pose on 9 11.
uh now camille harris stops herself from
from saying oh yeah it's definitely on
par
she doesn't need to say it
because this is what the left and the
media have been saying
for the last two years
that january 6 was just like 9 11 or in
fact uh
even worse than 9 11.
you could go through no reason for for
me to even go through on twitter go look
at clips from cable news uh many
examples of people on the left saying
that actually
january 6th was worse than 9 11.
but then the anniversary of 9 11 comes
along and and we see the remembrances
and you see again the footage of the
planes
flying in to the towers
and if it wasn't already clear to you
how absurd that claim is
um just seeing the visual again
like just compare the visual
the experience
of watching
passenger jets fly into skyscrapers
in america's largest city almost 3 000
people killed and then on the other hand
there's the experience of watching a
bunch of yahoos walk around the capitol
and take selfies at nancy pelosi's desk
i mean how could those things be
compared well they could be compared by
the left because
you know these are soulless
propagandists and
uh they're trying to demonize their
political opponents so that's part of it
obviously
the other part of it also is that
from from the perspective of the elites
from the perspective of democrats in
congress
them being
um
scared and traumatized on january 6th
was far worse than 3 000 people dying
because their own lives and their own
comfort is simply simply worth more than
the lives of
countless people
as far as they're concerned they they
equal like the lives of each of them
individually equal the lives of maybe 50
000 people
hillary clinton was there also on 9 11
to bring all this home for anyone not
catching the winks and nudges here she
is being i think most explicit at all of
all about it
what's going through your mind today 21
years later
well dana
every
time we approach september 11th i do
think about
everything that i saw all the people
that i met the families of those who
lost loved ones
so it is
indelibly um
part of my
memories and i feel
grateful
that um we were able to come together as
a country at that really terrible time
we put aside differences i wish we could
find ways of doing that again
we rebuilt new york
we have done our best to take care of
the
families that lost so much on that
terrible day
and we have also i think
been reminded
about
how important it is
to try to
deal with extremism of any kind
especially when it uses violence to try
to achieve political and ideological uh
goals
so
i'm one who thinks that there are
lessons still to be learned from what
happened to us on 9 11 that we should be
very aware of uh during this time in our
country and the world's history
so she starts by saying and i i really
can't stand listening to these people
uh talk anymore about
the unity after 9 11.
and um
that's something that that people still
reminisce
fondly about
on the right and the left well why can't
we be
united like we were after 9 11. first of
all
it should be clear to everyone by now
that that unity was
an aberration it was uh it was i
remember it too
i remember that the feeling now i was a
kid you know i was in high school but i
remember the feeling
for a very fleeting moment in time when
everyone was united and uh the next day
people were flying the american flags
and and uh singing the anthem and all
that kind of stuff there were a lot of
patriotic displays going on
but the reason why i was so fleeting is
because it wasn't real it was just
people caught up in the emotions of the
moment
if the unity was real there was actual
unity like we were we were coming
together around something real we had a
we had all of a sudden
some kind of shared value system
which you know the reason we don't have
unity in this country is that we don't
have a shared value system
and you're not going to suddenly
come up with a shared value system
because of a tragedy that's not how it
works
but if it was real unity then it
wouldn't have dissipated as quickly as
it all as it as it formed which it did
but i especially can't stomach hearing
it from people like hillary clinton
democrats
i remember the unity
after 9 11.
so you want unity and this is your way
of doing it
immediately after talking about the
unity and how much she wants unity
immediately after doing that she equates
half of the country with al qaeda
terrorists flying planes into buildings
that's the kind of unity she wants
and in a way it's it's true i mean they
do on on the left they do want unity in
a sense
but they want unity in the form of
submission
okay they they want you to submit to
them and then we can be unified like
that
on a bit of a lighter note uh more news
from the regime here's camila harris we
always enjoy these clips here she is uh
babbling nonsensically again
today the business of our work
is for the council to report on the work
that has occurred since our last meeting
across these areas
we will today also discuss the work
yet ahead the work we must still do
to continue to move forward
have you noticed what she does in these
clips because i love this move it's it's
the tell you could always tell
that that the kamela bot is about to go
on the fritz and start malfunctioning
because here's what she does she she
nods like she's agreeing with her own
statement
and uh that's what she does when she's
when she's
on the verge of launching into some
nonsensical ramble she always watch she
always does that so she'll go
today
the business of our work
is to work
on the ways we work
and together to work
as people who work
and we will work on working
and continue to work
and work in the future on the work yet
ahead
and the work still to do
and the work we must do
in the future
because the work's not complete
this is the format she begins with the
nod like she thinks she can trick us
it's like this uh she thinks she could
trick us into agreeing with whatever
nonsense she's about to spew by nodding
that way right and then at the end of
the ramble she always ends always
by restating a certain phrase in four
different ways
the work still to do the work yet to
come
and the work in the future
that's the format
all right so this ron desantis gave a
speech at the national conservatism
conference this week this weekend rather
some of his remarks well all of them
really but one portion in particular has
both leftists and libertarians in a bit
of a tizzy about this so here's someone
with reason magazine on twitter
uh reporting on on one portion of the
sanders to speech this is stephanie
slade who says
some of these are quoting desantis some
of these big companies are now
exercising quasi-public power desantis
says the latest example of a trend in
which conservatives conflate private
actions with government coercion
wow desantis says large businesses
aren't really private and thus don't
have first amendment rights
because they're doing the bidding of the
regime
so
i've saw many other quotes and clips
from that portion of his speech and the
whole speech by the way was excellent
but
the point he's actually trying to make
and it's a very good point and it's
something that republicans need to start
talking about more openly
um
and and it's it's a it's a now
libertarians might lament it and mourn
it but it's a good sign that republicans
more and more are getting away from this
kind of
reflexive defense of corporations that
was a problem among republicans for
decades
they felt they had to reflexively defend
any corporation that comes under attack
or criticism
because in order to defend the free
market you have to defend all the big
corporations
and it was also a response to on the
left where they're demonizing anyone
who's wealthy or any big corporation and
the millionaires and billionaires and so
it was kind of a it was a reaction to
that as well
but the point he's making about the big
corporations it's more nuanced than the
criticism of big corporations that you
hear from the bernie sanders types
uh the point that he's making
is that the big corporations
specifically big tech
often work as an arm of the government
so
if the government realizes that it can't
do something constitutionally not that
that usually stops the government from
doing what it wants but if it feels that
it can't get away with doing a
particular thing
then it will go
to the big tech
monopoly
which again functions as an arm of the
regime and say well we can't do this we
need you to do it
perfect examples what we heard from
um mark zuckerberg
you know they wanted to
the the the
inconvenience
uh
revelations about hunter biden's laptop
now the government couldn't come and
like start arresting people if they post
about hunter biden's laptop the fbi
couldn't come and start arresting you
for that and they might get to the point
where they'll do something like that and
be more open about it but at the time
they felt like they couldn't really do
that
they were being constrained like it or
not and they didn't like it they were
being constrained by the first amendment
so they went to facebook and said we
need you guys to take this stuff down
because just call it misinformation it's
not really misinformation but take it
down anyway
so this is the way of this is this is
the way that the tyrants sidestep the
constitution is by getting their allies
their functionaries in big tech to do it
for them
that's what the santis is pointing out
that's the workaround
that is unacceptable and republicans
need to start talking about and need to
talk about plans but how
what are we going to do to stop that
moving on to this the crime wave isn't
just hitting the continental united
states here's a report i want to play
some of this out of hawaii about the
crime over there let's watch
just six weeks ago a thief assaulted and
maced a longtime employee of kc market
leaving the elderly woman's eyes burning
and injuring her back
but the incident was just the beginning
of a series of thefts including a
burglary this morning at the 40-year-old
neighborhood store they live in
trepidation and fear every day now it's
not you know safe for them
these people prey on the elderly over
the past several months the owners of kc
market says crime has exploded in the
kalihi area
roy chang's parents who asked not to be
identified have run the mom and pop shop
peacefully for years the couple know
most of their neighbors and customers by
name
i come back yes okay
you know all the kids from the
elementary come over here grab musubis
and get all the drinks and it's
convenient for all of us all the crimes
is really sad and then it's affecting
you know everybody not only resources
the neighborhood too one of the most
disturbing aspects of this uh trend this
crime wave which again affects not just
uh the continental united states but all
the way out in hawaii as well
is that is it so often the elderly are
targets of it which is i suppose not a
surprise they're vulnerable
and can be easily overpowered and so
these criminal
deviant degenerate psychopaths and
sociopaths you know they don't care
they're gonna they're gonna
you know go after the the weakest person
that they can
which is why
uh talk about things that we should be
discussing one of the things driving
this crisis is
the fact that we are producing as a
society
so many people who are utterly
indifferent to human life
uh indifferent indifferent to the the
suffering
that they'll cause
indifferent altogether they just don't
care
this is why i've always said that
instead of making a special case out of
hate crimes we hear so much about hate
crimes we should be focusing on
indifferent crimes
that's that's what we're actually
plagued by as a society
crimes of indifference
crimes motivated by hate aren't as bad
as crimes motivated by indifference
i mean they're terrible
but on one hand you have a person driven
by hate
and on the other hand you have someone
who's driven by being totally empty and
hollow inside without even the energy to
hate
now the person driven by hate there's
something there's there's like some hope
there maybe
okay you want to talk about
rehabilitation maybe that's someone who
could be they need to be punished
severely
but maybe that's someone if it's hate
that's inside their heart then maybe
that's something that you can
you could you could take that that's
something you could grab on to
and um
and maybe there's hope for that person
you can rehabilitate them you can you
know they could see the error in their
ways
maybe but someone who just doesn't care
at all
there's no concern whatsoever for other
people
their violence is motivated and they're
not even a lot of this the the crime
that you saw there woman gets elderly
woman is maced
the guy takes something out of the cash
register
is he desperate and starving not that
that would make it okay but he's not
even desperate his people are basically
comfortable
they don't even need what they're
stealing they're just doing it because
that's an even bigger challenge when you
have people like that when you have a
whole society full of people like that
um then you have
true chaos which is what we're dealing
with now
all right byu has finally released the
results of its investigation into the
phantom n-word shouted by an invisible
person at a volleyball game uh this is
the
you know the incident that was talked
about quite a bit on espn and and uh
stephen a smith was shouting about it
and lebron james was talking about it a
bunch of athletes celebrities espn they
were all over this story
but now that we have the conclusion of
the story this is how this generally
works
they jump on the bandwagon at the very
beginning when all we have is a claim
that somebody made and then
when the claim is actually investigated
and now we have the result that's when
they that's when the media jumps off
they're not interested anymore
so here's what byu this is the statement
they released
as part of our commitment to take any
claims of racism seriously byu has
completed its investigation into the
allegation that racial heckling and
slurs took place at the duke versus byu
women's volleyball match on august 26th
we reviewed all available video and
audio recordings including security
footage and raw footage from all camera
angles taken by byu tv of the match with
broadcasting audio removed to ensure
that the noise from the stands could be
heard more clearly we also reached out
to more than 50 individuals who attended
the event duke athletic department
personnel and student athletes byu
athletic department personnel and
student athletes event security and
management and fans who were in the
arena that evening including many of the
fans in the on-court student section
from our extensive review we have not
found any evidence to corroborate the
allegation that fans engaged in racial
heckling or uttered racial slurs at the
event as we stated earlier we would not
tolerate any conduct that would make a
student athlete feel unsafe that's the
reason for our immediate response and
our thorough investigation as a result
of our investigation we have lifted the
ban on the fan who was identified as
having uttered racial slurs during the
match we have not found any evidence
that the individual engaged in such an
activity byu would sincerely apologize
to that fan for any hardship the ban has
caused oh byu sincerely apologizes for
the hardship of
baselessly labeling this guy a racist
not just a racist but somebody who is so
suicidally racist someone who is so
overcome
by their hatred for black people that he
would
sit in the stands
and shout the n-word over and over again
ruining his own life in the process
that's the level of racism that this guy
was accused of
but now byu apologizes
so they
essentially convicted this
kid of racism and then after the
conviction went back to investigate to
see if that really happened and then
realized that oh this didn't happen at
all
and as i said when this um
you know before the investigation was
complete we talked about it a couple of
weeks ago
yeah i'll be curious to see what the
investigation turns up and they turned
up you know nothing because nothing
happened
this was this was entirely invented
even before seeing the the investigation
like if you're gonna jump to a
conclusion about something like this
it makes the most sense
far and away the most sense to jump to
the conclusion that it's made up because
these cases are almost always made up
and as i said at the time you if you if
you
if you just have the basic understanding
of human nature you would realize
how likely it is that something like
this is a hoax
because we know that there's an enormous
social incentive to invent hoaxes like
this
but then on the other end of the
spectrum there is no social incentive
whatsoever to engage in the behavior
that this kid was accused of engaging in
you would have to actually be a lunatic
you would have to be a suicidal crazy
person to do that even if you're racist
because you are forfeiting your life you
you are you are ruining your life
now is there going to be any
accountability is espn going to come
back around and apologize stephen a
smith lebron james of course not
because again it goes back to social
incentive there's no incentive there's
no reason why they should apologize or
own up to what they did
they jumped on the hoax bandwagon turned
out to be a hoax and they pretend that
never happened and move on to the next
thing
same story repeats over and over and
over again
all right finally here's a familiar
lecture that we hear a lot on tick tock
but each new rendition adds a new
wrinkle and so this is a tick tocker
explaining
why it's transphobic
to not date trans people you know if you
don't date trans people then you're
transphobic and he says that this is
true even if your preference for members
of the opposite sex is driven by a
desire to have children he says that's
not a good enough excuse that's not
going to let you off the hook
and he explains why here
i disagree with this and i still think
it's harmful to trans people you can
still have biological children with a
trans partner in the same way that like
two lesbians can have a biological child
two gay men can have a biological child
yes it's a lot harder to have biological
children when you're not in a cis-het
relationship but it's still possible is
it expensive yes but that's something
that i feel like a lot of people in the
lgbt community go through if they want
kids i don't i
no i'm too poor to have children but for
my lgbt people that do want to have kids
and you want a loving partner to have
those children with i feel like you
still shouldn't be discriminating
against your partner if they're trans
when looking for a partner it still
feeds into this stigma that trans people
are not their gender when they are a
trans man is a man and a trans female is
a female it just makes the community
more loving and accepting
uh okay
just to clarify a few things here first
of
all the idea that you shouldn't
discriminate when looking for a partner
is
obviously nonsensical though the whole
process of looking for a partner is a
process of discrimination
because what is discriminate means
discriminate means simply to
um to make distinctions to
differentiate that's all discrimination
means
so we all discriminate in our lives
every single day i mean practically
every second of the day you are engaging
in as a thinking person as a rational
agent you are engaging in discrimination
in that you are differentiating you are
recognizing distinctions it wouldn't be
possible to operate in the world if you
couldn't do that
and especially when you're deciding on a
partner you're choosing a mate you're
choosing friends whatever to choosing a
job it's it's um it is a whole parade of
of discriminatory decisions that you're
making you're differentiating you're
deciding i want this i don't want that
i'm looking for this i'm not looking for
that
now what we're being told on tiktok is
that you should go into the dating scene
with no preferences at all
period like you're just walking in blind
and you'll take the first person that
you stumble across doesn't matter who it
is makes no difference to you
another thing to clarify is that
two men cannot have a biological child
together neither can two women um it's
even if a gay couple has all the money
in the world it's not just that it's
expensive it's that it's physically
impossible now a man can combine his
sperm with a woman's egg and create a
baby in a petri dish
but then it's not the gay couple's
biological child it's the biological
couple of one of the gay guys along with
some random woman
so same goes the other way with lesbians
is it's not possible two men cannot have
biological shots impossible and i want
you to really think about the fact that
i need to explain this i need to explain
it actually needs to be explained that
two men can't make a baby
it needs to be explained to a person who
looks to be an adult or nearly an adult
and and probably is educated
still we need to explain that two men
cannot make a baby
he also says it's transphobic to not
date trans people this again is
something we hear a lot now the correct
answer to that charge is uh is okay
and
i mean if that's how you define
transphobia you could define it however
you want you you made up this stupid
term so i guess it's up to you to define
um
and uh fine that's cool
if you're saying that transphobia is
when someone doesn't want a data trans
person then okay then i'm transphobic
that's fine
you're admitting yeah
sure
that's all you have to do with these
kinds of uh charges when they're made
against you
that is the one sure way to disarm
the person who's coming after you
because once you accept that wow that's
transphobic all right fine and it's
transphobic so are you admitting you're
a transphobe
yes
well but that's you can't that's not
good okay well that's your opinion
i just really wish if i had a 100
billion dollars to start my own social
media
site
um i tell you what i would do
i would de-platform people and ban them
purely on the basis of being stupid that
that's the kind of deep platforming that
i would like to see
if you are this damned stupid
that you think for example two men can
have babies putting ideology aside for a
moment if you are that level of stupid
you don't get to be on any platform
that's it
you shouldn't have access to an audience
because think about that there are
people who are this stupid and yet they
have an audience that they can
that they're offering guidance to and
advice
you shouldn't be speaking to thousands
or millions of people if you're the
one of the dumbest people on planet
earth
if i had the ability that's how i would
de-platform people
uh let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
hope you had a good weekend by the way i
uh mine was was quiet my wife and kids
were out of town so
um you know i really went crazy cut
loose got a little wild
you know how it goes
i finished a book i'd been reading and i
watched a documentary and then i was in
bed by nine that's how i spent
my my time my freedom
oh and i did some research on what sort
of freshwater fish worked best in a
75-gallon community tank so that was
about two hours of entertainment in
between the book and the documentary
that's my life that's who i am it's a
sad state of affairs but at least my
aquarium
will be pretty great i also noticed
somewhere in the midst of all this i i
did i checked uh twitter briefly
and i was i was trending for i don't
even know why
i checked because someone
texted me and said why are you trending
on twitter i said i am i don't know i
haven't even been on
and i went and looked and i i honestly
couldn't tell why i was
i just knew that if i'm trending it's
never because people are saying nice
things about me i've never been trending
because everyone is there's never been a
day was like let's all say nice things
about matt walsh today let's uh let's
make them feel good never been training
for that reason it's always because
people on the left are upset or whatever
you know it's always something like that
and um
i can say it's it's somewhat freeing
the fact that the pitchfork mob exists
almost entirely on the internet
there's just a certain comfort certain
freedom and knowing that
i can go and look at my phone and say oh
a bunch of people on the left are upset
i have no idea why they're all talking
about me they're upset
i don't care just put the phone down get
back to the book you're reading
to know that there are a bunch of people
out there
attacking you and talking about you and
saying how upset they are
and
you're not even paying attention to it
you're off somewhere else completely
that's kind of nice
jeff says matt you never explained why
you support the woke nfl you rail
against woke corporations and then go on
and on about your favorite nfl team i
support you on most things but this
seems like a blind spot well i don't
think it's accurate to say i go on and
on about it i think i mentioned football
and the fact that i'm a ravens fan once
a year or something if if that often
um it came up a lot during the fantasy
draft with training company but that's
just because i'm bad at drafting and all
i did was draft ravens players which is
why i ended up with like
nine total fantasy points this weekend
and also why i'm gonna end up being the
one who has to go to a wnba game which i
have to admit is maybe the funniest
outcome so
not that i want to go but i just as
someone who can appreciate a fun
trolling thing i i do admit that that is
kind of funny even if i'm the one who
has to suffer through it
as for the nfl
it seems to me that they first of all
dialed way back on the political stuff
uh they responded to the fan outcry in
that way fans didn't want it they dialed
back not because they wanted to but
because they had no choice um also the
players aren't generally woke now some
are
but there are a lot of conservatives
there are a lot of outspoken christians
actually in the nfl so this is kind of a
misconception it's not not all
professional athletes as a group are
woke now you get a lot of that in the
nba
a lot of that in the wnba if you can
call them professional athletes
not as much in in football actually
um also the product that they're putting
out is not woke okay it's not like
disney putting out a product meant to
indoctrinate people especially kids the
product that the nfl puts out is
football it's a game you know there's
nothing leftist about the game itself
now sure the company makes woke gestures
from time to time
but if you're saying that we should
boycott
any company
that even gestures in that direction
i can respect that i can respect that
that point of view i can respect that if
you actually put it into action but if
if but putting into action means that
you certainly aren't gonna be using any
streaming service except for the daily
wire uh you're not you can't be watching
any movies by any hollywood production
companies at all
or going to any retail stores
or using an iphone
or any other smartphone
or any internet provider or it's like
now if if that's how you're living i
really do respect it i don't know how
you're communicating with me right now
if that is how you're living but
i i respect that if that's what you're
doing
i somewhat doubt it though
which doesn't mean that we as
conservatives shouldn't boycott any
companies at all we talked about this
last week i'm fully in favor of that it
just means we should be a lot more
targeted
in our
boycotts
all right matt hayden says hey matt just
to clarify the bluey story you were
unsure about it's actually quite the
opposite of injecting wokeness disney
plus has removed several episodes from
the show's catalogue including an
episode where bluey's parents teach her
and her sister about teasing because it
promoted bullying the show is charming
beautifully written and animated and
provides great lessons for kids as a
conservative and catholic father i
cannot recommend it enough my wife and
i's favorite episode is sleepy time if
you want a sample to get an idea of the
show's quality so you're saying this is
an actual anti-woke children's show
that's popular that's out there i
i will i will
check it out i will take you up on the
recommendation
um scott says so flannel friday is
actually a thing now is this the first
time in history matt didn't stand his
ground on such an important issue no
it's not because i had no ground i was
very clear about that i had no ground on
this whatsoever
i care less about what i wear than
almost everyone else apparently this is
something everyone else is fighting
about i'm caught in the middle with
people like literally tearing at my
clothes it's a very disturbing situation
to be in i don't care that much myself
that's
but that is the spirit of flannels in
general it's like you don't wear
flannels because you're passionate about
flannels
you wear them because it's like it's
just something to put on
and it's comfortable and like i said you
don't usually don't have to iron it as
much
let's see
nate says matt in the members portion
you talked about how our culture
belittles stay-at-home mothers and
mothers in general my favorite take on
this is from g.k chesterton from his
book what's wrong with the world quote
it's not difficult to see why the female
became the emblem of the universal
nature surrounded her with very young
children required to be taught so much
as anything is everything babies need
not to be taught a trade but to be
introduced to a world to put the matter
shortly woman is generally shut up in a
house with a human being at the time
when he asks all the questions that
there are and some that aren't
how can it be a large career to teach
other people's children about the rule
of three and a small career to tell
one's own children about the universe
how could it be broad to be the same
thing to everyone and narrow to be
everything to someone
i hope someone reads this and finds it
enlightening well i do but
i also somewhat resent
when i'm rambling about something and
then someone sends me
you know a passage from gk test
chesterton says oh you know gk chester
was talking about the same thing you
were talking about and then it's way
better and more eloquent than anything i
could ever say
makes me feel worse it's harmful to my
self-esteem but i do appreciate it
although you are banned from the show of
course
we have a big announcement today candace
owens is back from maternity leave with
a vengeance her brand new show candace
owens launches today at 3 p.m central on
daily wire plus and we'll take on the
big topics of the day uncover lies and
expose the hypocrisy and news and
politics and you know it's going to be
done in typical candace style fearless
and resolute this is everything you love
about candace only now she's streaming
five days a week you'll not want to miss
her explosive first episode which
premieres today trust me when i say this
is huge so check out candace owens
podcast on apple podcast spotify daily
wire plus or wherever you listen to
podcast now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well a few weeks ago we told you about a
new show on apple tv called gutsy it
follows the adventures of hillary
clinton and chelsea clinton as they sit
around uh planning jizz lane maxwell's
murder in prison
sorry that was that was the show concept
that apple turned down which is a shame
because it would be much better than
what they ended up with the real show
documents the clinton girls as they
traipse around the country talking to
women who inspire them women like
kim kardashian amy schumer wanda sykes
gloria steinem
serial killer eileen warnos
actually that last person was executed
which means that hillary will have to
wait a few years to talk to her anyway
it is without question
the worst show or film concept that
anyone has ever had i think i can say
that it makes batgirl look like a good
investment by comparison
if you didn't catch the trailer but or
even if you did we're gonna watch it
again here it is
we're hitting the road to shine a light
on women who inspire us to be bolder and
braver
leadership doesn't look one way you're
not gonna break me down you'll get worn
out before i do
i believe in second chances
[Applause]
every single person makes some impact on
the planet every day
[Applause]
we can choose what difference we make
[Music]
well we can only assume based on the
trailer that the name of the show gutsy
is meant to describe the courage
required of the viewers who are watching
it and i'm being very generous by saying
viewers with an s
now
we knew that a show starring the likes
of hillary clinton and kim kardashian
would just by its very existence be
brutal and torturous enough as to
violate every protocol of the geneva
convention but even the darkest
imagination could not have anticipated
just how bad it would actually be
because the show has now been released a
fact that comes as news to
everyone just as it will come as news to
any residents of connecticut that your
state has a wnba team by the way and
it's currently competing in the finals
and i learned that myself this morning
when i looked it up so that i could make
that joke hillary hillary's new show
debuted and people.com
has a summary of what we're all missing
by not watching it here's what it says
she might be a champion of gutsy women
but hillary clinton doesn't think it
should be an act of courage for women to
talk openly about the health and
function of their lady parts
as clinton's gutsy docu-series with
daughter chelsea premieres friday on
apple tv plus including episodes with
wanda sykes talking about menopause
um and with migondi stallian talking
about her sex positive whop the former
secretary of state recalls her own
experience with menopause and that
provocative rap now we do have a clip of
hillary's discussion about wap
uh believe me i would like to spare you
from having to watch it but i have no
choice your own sins have brought you to
this crossroads you must watch as
atonement for whatever evil you have
done in your life but before we endure
that trauma together
let's hear what hillary has to say about
menopause this should be at least
slightly less devastating to listen to
um going back to the article says after
a certain age we all seem to inherit
these new things on our bodies hillary
74 tells people it was towards the end
of the second term after i turned 50 in
1997 that i began to go through
menopause and it was something that you
didn't talk about in those days my
friends and i would talk about it or
roll our eyes but not publicly that's
why we really wanted to talk about it
with wanda because it's a universal
experience for us thank goodness we're
getting into a time when women's health
and especially now with all the
challenges about reproductive health are
forcing this conversation out of the
shadows and into the daylight
now hillary insists that uh somehow her
menopause has something to do with the
abortion conversation continuing quote
it's astonishing to me how ignorant a
lot of these men legislators are in a
lot of these states making these laws
about women's bodies she says
the things they say the things that they
think the ignorance that they display is
breathtaking so the more we can talk
about it chelsea jumps in it's dangerous
stigma is so deadly when it comes to
public health hillary acknowledges
stigma played a role in her silence in
the white house
looking back i mean it wasn't yet at the
point of our social or psychic
development that i would have said oh
okay the first lady is going through
menopause here i go watch out everybody
now a couple of things here
first to fruitlessly reiterate
it's not just men who support pro-life
laws it's actually not even mostly men
also i'm not sure of a single example
where pro-life legislation has betrayed
an ignorance of women's bodies we're all
aware that women's bodies bear children
we know that i mean we know that
those of us on the right are aware of
that it's actually on the left where
there's confusion on that point but on
our side we know that our point is
simply that
these children should not be killed
that's all we're saying but second
perhaps more to the point here hillary
says that back in the 90s we weren't at
the point of our social psychic
development where the first lady would
announce her menopause publicly
well are we at that point now
should we be
why would you want to make a public
announcement about your menopause
she says that she talked about her
menopause with her friends but she
didn't talk about it on the public stage
yes and
what else would you have done held a
press conference issued an official
statement on white house letterhead
called for a national day of mourning
obviously you didn't talk about your
menopause publicly that would have been
totally bizarre and weird and
inappropriate
besides the public was hearing more than
enough already about the various bodily
functions occurring in the white house
during the clinton administration so we
didn't need to hear more
we have this totally ridiculous idea in
our culture that
if we don't discuss something publicly
then it's it's stigmatized
feminists will say the same thing about
their periods they lament the
stigmatization of a woman's menstrual
cycle
but again there's no stigma we're all
aware that it's a thing that happens in
and to the bodies of women that doesn't
mean that we all need to talk about it
over the dinner table or that you need
to announce it into a megaphone
you also don't need to make a public
pronouncement about every fart or burp
or bowel movement
these are all things that everyone does
yet we are discouraged from making a
spectacle out of these activities
doesn't mean we're oppressed it just
means that we're expected to be at least
moderately civilized
but there are those for whom moderately
civilized is a bar too high to get over
those like meghan estallian who appeared
in another episode of the show where she
and hillary and chelsea had the
conversation that you were hoping i
would forget about and not play the clip
of but today is not your lucky day so
here it is
chelsea follows rap music she has
ever since she was a little girl
but i kind of
came to awareness of you with the cardi
b wap
i've always wanted to do a song with
cardi as soon as she sent me the song i
think i sent it back to her like the
next day and it was just so exciting the
men they seem so confident in what
they're saying and they don't have no
problem with talking about their
sexuality and how they gonna have sex
with you so i was like well
i could do that and it's gonna sound
fire coming from a woman it's great to
see women be so kind of fierce that is
my
life's mission to make sure that i'm
always unapologetically me
yes well on the bright side
meghan says that she took a day to write
her verse of the song which is a lot
longer than i thought it would have
taken she put more thought into it than
i assumed i'll give her that
after all her contribution to the song
indeed the whole song itself is the sort
of thing that an illiterate crackhead
could scribble on a bathroom stall in
about 95 seconds while in the middle of
overdosing
but she was more thoughtful than that
which i mean perhaps makes it all the
more pathetic but
whatever the case and and if we can
somehow move past the intense revulsion
we feel about the way this subject is
being discussed and especially about who
is discussing it
the lessons being taught here are truly
terrible
first megan notes that uh male rappers
are disgusting pigs constantly you know
saying very crass and sexual things
her way of correcting this problem is to
be an even more disgusting pig herself
this truly is the feminist mantra
i hate it when men behave in
objectionable ways so i will behave in
an even more objectionable way
she then claims that her life's mission
is to be unapologetically me
that is of course the worst sort of
mission you can have in life it is a
recipe for failure in 99.9 of cases
the rap and pop industries package this
kind of message and they sell it to kids
forgetting to mention that almost none
of them will end up as successful as the
celebrities they're emulating if they
continue to emulate them
because unapologetically me in this
context means
i'm going to be a stupid boorish
self-centered obnoxious idiot
and expect everyone to just fall over
themselves and worship me anyway because
i'm me
the celebrities who promote this mission
this message will indeed themselves be
worshipped no matter how dumb and
repulsive they are but for most people
being dumb and repulsive just means that
nobody will want to be around you or be
your friend or marry you or hire you for
a job
you will be alone and bitter and
miserable forever
but you will have helped me on the
stallion get rich and that's all she
cares about and that's why she is
canceled and hillary clinton is
cancelled and this show is especially
most certainly in the end cancelled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move on to the members
segment hope to see you over there if
not talk to you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you